How many guards on each level. Never more than 12.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full Star Wars Andor episode 9 video there
were a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes there was even a really quick blink and
you'll miss it Easter egg for George Lucas's Cameo
during Revenge of the Sith you may have spotted
I'll talk about later in the video careful for
spoilers for the episode if you haven't seen it
yet we'll just start at the beginning and work our
way through shot by shot talking about Easter eggs
and WTF moments starting with the episode title
nobody's listening which is a reference to andor's
conversation with Andy circus's Kino Loi character
about the guards at the Imperial prison not caring
about them nearly as much as Kino Loy thinks that
they do and it's meant to be all part of that
same energy when he told luthen earlier about the
Empire not really caring about that much anymore
because they've grown so fat and lazy with power
they become so LAX the other connection to that
conversation is that when he was telling luthen
about that they were talking about the steer guard
Imperial base because that was where Andor stole
the star path unit from that they've been talking
about recently and during one of the ISB meetings
they say that they captured a rebel pilot near
that steergard base it's just more of the ISB
is slowly closing in on luthen and the rest of
the rebels activity in finding out how they're
all connected to each other but the whole idea
with the prison that Andor was talking to Kino Loy
about because he keeps going on and on about the
guards activity and making his escape plans going
full Shawshank Redemption like making his Escape
slowly as we speak is that actually escaping from
that Imperial prison should be way easier than
you might think Point number one it seems like
all they have to do to escape being shocked by
the floors is literally just steal the boots off
of the guards that's probably going to be one of
the first things that they try to do when they
actually do make their prison break just grab
everybody's shoes everybody put them on let them
shock the floors all they want they won't hurt us
because remember the whole idea of the guards said
that they don't walk around with weapons because
they don't need them because they have that whole
floor system of just shocking all the bulkheads
so literally all you have to do is steal their
boots and you're good the actual opening scene
is of Dedra interrogating big saw and ferricks
right after the end of the last week's episode
the whole metaphor about her fishing correctly and
not rushing to grab things that they first catch
in the net is all about tracking things back to
Andor and ultimately to luthen like she's caught
Bix here she's the lesser prey early in the nets
and she's waiting for bigger fish to show up they
bring in the Doctor Gores character to interrogate
her along with everybody else he's a brand new
character in Star Wars but this is a very familiar
position within the Empire I love the way that she
talked about their new interrogation methods
calling them a unique interview system and
encouragement and it's meant to be a lot of the
same energy of Han Solo being interrogated during
Empire Strikes Back or Princess Leia being
interrogated on the Death Star by Darth Vader
but they try to be more Insidious about it this
time because of the whole speech about the way
they developed their new system for interrogating
people in a much more efficient way he explains
the backstory of this Dison Fray species on an
outer rim planet that had this Insurgency that
the Empire dealt with by basically killing off
all the diazonites in a very public way like
they live stream the execution of this species
and it's a reference to the Empire's tactics
of how they tried to dissuade other Rebels from
Insurgency like this is what will happen to you
if you come against us it's a bit of a reference
to a New Hope where Grand Moff Tarkin uses the
death star to destroy Alderaan in a very public
way so the entire galaxy sees what's happening
like the Joker's line during The Dark Knight movie
it's about sending a message so the really crazy
WTF thing that the empire did is they took the
dysonite's dying screams and processed them into
a more efficient torture method in this device
like a helmet they put on people's heads like the
dysonite's regular dying screams already induced
just regular extreme emotional distress on their
own the Empire jacked that way up and now it's
just much more efficient than torturing you the
old-fashioned way they imply they're going to run
Bix through this treatment a couple of times like
they say that that's really bad like the more you
do this the worse it's going to be because later
in the episode when we see her recovering it seems
like she hasn't given up any information on Andor
or luthen yet back in the Imperial prison they set
up all the medical problems that oolaf winds up
happening you kind of know where this is headed
like I said the Shawshank Redemption metaphors
during the episode he's like the old prisoner
who winds up dying just before his sentence is
up and is being a big tragic thing inspiring the
other prisoners to escape even faster everyone
press F to pay respects to uloff they set up this
whole freak out early in the episode on level 2
with everybody being confused about why things are
going crazy on the different level the reason why
Andy's serkis' Kino Loy character freaks out at
this point in the episode early on is because he's
so close to getting out he has just a little over
200 days so he doesn't want any of his chances
of actually getting out being hurt by anything
weird happening on his level but then when uloff
actually does go down and they bring in the med
tech we find out what actually happened on level
two and it winds up being this big Catalyst this
big call to action for Aquino Lloyd's character
so I actually feel like Andy serkis' character
had a more interesting Arc in this episode than
Andor actually did when the med tech comes in
he basically helps mercy kill ulath like no he's
had a stroke there's no way he's going to recover
he might only have 40 days left but this this is
a mercy killing him because you're never getting
out none of us are ever getting out of this prison
because of the big mistake that the Empire just
made on level two and we find out the reason why
the Empire killed all the people on level 2 which
is also paying off andor's earlier conversation
with Kino Loy about the Empire thinking them
less than human like we're worth less to them
than droids because we're so easy to replace we're
like cattle to them there was a prisoner on one of
the levels that was released per his sentence
previously the guards made a mistake during his
release and he wound up just being put back in as
another prisoner on level two and to cover up the
guards accident they just wound up killing all the
prisoners there so they wouldn't get in trouble
with their own superiors in the Empire and now
because of that because they realized that the
people were talking between levels that the other
prisoners know about what happened they're not
going to let anybody out of the prison so if you
remember the whole reason why Andy serkis' Kino
Loy character was so hardcore such a Taskmaster
for all the people on this level was because he
was so close to getting out now that he knows
that he's not going to get it out like oh this
is going to be a mercy this guy dying the rest
of us we're gonna have it real bad because the
rest of us are never getting out of here so I
love the turn on Andy serkis' face and in his
character later as they're walking out at the end
of the episode where he finally answers andor's
question about the guards in his Escape Plan like
how many guards per level at any given time so the
whole idea now is it'll be a more concerted Prison
Break effort even though we make all the Shawshank
Redemption metaphors it was just him escaping on
his own this time it sounds like they're going to
be a bunch of the prisoners trying to escape all
at once we'll see how much longer the prison Arc
winds up running I don't know if they plan for
that to run to the end of the season because
there are 12 episodes total because it sounds like
they're going to try to escape either at the end
of next week's episode or like right after that
like now that they realize that they're all going
to be stuck in there forever no matter what none
of the guards have any actual weapons they just
wear those boots they're all probably going to
try to escape as quickly as possible the other
big storyline of the episode was mon mothma's
storyline so we start with her inside the Senate
with the other Senators just barely caring about
what she's talking about she's basically trying
to speak out on the emperor's new actions where
he ratcheted up all the security measures taking
away a lot of people's personal freedoms around
the Galaxy the whole idea is that the rest of the
Senators could basically care less about it that's
why you see all their lights turning off in their
boots like they're all turning their booze off and
taking off for the day like peace I'm out of here
I don't want to hear anything bad about this who
cares you also may have spotted the George Lucas
Cameo Easter egg in the background too in this
booth here where you see the blue-skinned aliens
wearing those special headdresses that's the same
race the George Lucas Cameo as is Baron Paponoida
during Revenge of the Sith so the joke here is
that George Lucas's Senator character bailed on
this meeting that's because most of them are meant
to be kind of like her husband content to keep
their heads in the sand and live the lie that the
emperor and the Empire are not totally evil some
of the Senators though are probably legit evil
we also find out that vel sartha is mon mothma's
cousin from chandrila her rich mother or father
is mon mothma's sister or brother previously we
knew that she was from a rich family now we just
know a little bit more we don't know exactly about
her parents but it sounds like find out soon it
seems like they're both on the same page about
them being involved with the rebellion and luthen
but because of the way they compartmentalize
information between different Rebel cells and all
their activities they don't know everything that
each other is doing like mon mothma doesn't know
about vel sartha pulling off the hiest on aldhani.
Vel Sartha just barely learns about what's
happening with take home as banks in the plan to
move all this Rebel money but I think what they're
doing with their storyline and they kind of set
this up during her conversation with take coma
later is the idea that she needs a giant big loan
of money is that they'll use all the money that
Vel Sartha stole like the 80 million plus credits
and put it in the banks use the banks on chandrila
to move it all that's what her own conversation
would take Homa is about like oh you need a big
deposit to cover up all the money that you've
been taking out well we have a giant pile of money
just sitting over there with luthen when he says
the Empire is going to be checking her deposits
very soon that just puts a ticking clock on it
meaning that they're gonna have to put the deposit
wherever that comes from either from the shady
person that take homea had set her up with or from
luthen with his stolen credits from aldhani before
the end of the season when he says that time isn't
unlimited the funny thing about that is that it's
only not true inside the world between worlds
where you have access to all of time and space
because it's sort of like a nexus in the force
of time and space we'll see if they ever wind
up doing that in live action obviously Andor is
not the series where they would do that in maybe
when we get to the Ahsoka series The really shady
person that tay kolma wants to set her up with is
called Davos Skolden and he's basically a person
with treasury connections who's using his position
for evil he's kind of like a white collar crime
boss so to speak in manmathma is objecting just
because she doesn't want to have to owe political
favors to him which he will definitely ask her
to do if he gives her money is basically like a
political official taking mob money like they're
definitely going to ask you for favors then I love
the syril karn and storyline of this episode too
just showing you how obsessed he is he is like
the face of stalker simps now in the Star Wars
Universe they have all these meetings outside the
ISB which in and of themselves are just meant to
show you you how deadly inefficient they are in
just working through all these Solutions will
make it look like the pilot killed themselves
so the other Rebels won't get on to us that we
know that they're going to pull a heist and they
won't get spooked remember the Kreeger group that
the pilot comes from is the group that luthen
wanted Saw Gerrera to work with so the whole
idea is that the ISB is successful in getting all
these Rebels during this Big Heist that they know
that they're going to try and pull off it would
potentially help them crush the Rebellion before
it has a chance to get started because we know
the rebels do wind up coming together it sounds
like they're going to be unsuccessful though
but like right after this last meeting deadro
walks out of the ISB and up comes syril karn
and saying that he's been standing outside the
ISB on a regular basis waiting to see if he might
find her stalking a supervisor at the ISB is like
the most dangerous thing you could possibly do in
the heart of the Empire's power make all the Star
Wars simp jokes you want like he is maximum simp
for deadra now one of the bigger questions that
came out of this conversation though like
bigger points of interest is the idea that
Dedra actually helped him get a promotion rather
than the opposite rather than getting him fired
and put off in some Outer Rim Planet which he
actually threatened him with like if you stalk
me even more I will definitely put you into prison
in the outer rim why would deadra go so far is to
get him a promotion did she want him to be buried
with work is this part of some bigger plot line
because there's all these mysteries about who
dedra really is there's a couple different ways
they could go with her character if she could
be totally brand new character we've never seen
before that has no prior connection to Andor or
she could also wind up being andor's long-lost
sister so she could always have tried to get him
that promotion to purposefully keep him busy in
a way from trying to find Andor because it's
so weird that someone in the ISB someone who's
that evil would try to do a favor for someone else
without trying to get something back in return and
it sounds like deadra never wants to see him again
why would she get him a promotion and then deny
that she did it post all your theories about that
in the comments below because it sounds like she
was just trying to keep him away from Andor that
was part of that whole funny conversation with his
mother too like I just got a promotion I'm gonna
have way more work I'll be way busier either way
he's probably not going to be deterred like he's
probably going to continue trying to harass and
stalk her until she agrees to either bring him
on board or there's some bigger twist but I do
love it now that Dedra has just as much reason
to hate him because he won't leave her alone as
Andor does like please just leave us alone dude
if there's any other Easter eggs or references in
the episode that you spotted that I didn't talk
about in the video just write them Below in the
comments my full episode 10 video will post next
week after they release it we also found out the
Mandalorian season 3 is probably going to premiere
February 22nd and I believe the Ahsoka series
will start a little bit later in the year after
that probably in June maybe July we'll get more
footage for the Mandalorian season 3 The Ahsoka
series and a lot of the other stuff too pretty
soon everyone click here for my new house of the
dragon season 2 video about creegan stark in the
return to Winterfell and click here for my house
the dragon alternate ending and deleted scenes
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!